she told many stories
but her colleagues say a lot more are
now left untold
ones only shirina boracle could so
brilliantly tell
highly regarded in palestine as a
passionate active and courageous
journalist she was devoted to telling
the palestinian story
as well as covering wars and conflicts
the veteran al jazeera journalists
reported on the smallest details of
palestinians lives conveying the harsh
realities of life under israeli military
occupation
but she too became a victim of israeli
forces when she was shot and killed
while reporting from janine in the
occupied west bank the place where
sharing was shot has turned into a
shrine where people come to pay tribute
to her
among them is iman frihat she tells us
she met the reporter in 2002 and says
shireen helped her find out her children
were alive
they told me my house was destroyed and
i thought my sons were killed under the
rubble i thought i lost them but shireen
found out they were arrested how would i
not grieve her
palestinians continue honoring shireen
who they called the daughter of
palestine paintings and murals of her
are ways some people use to keep her
legacy alive
a street in the heart of ramallah where
al jazeera's offices are based now
carries her name
sheen would pay attention to everyone
whether she meets a child or an old lady
she would sit with them for as long as
it takes to understand their story and
grievances
still she has authority while
interviewing politicians she was never
biased to any political party
all of this alongside her professional
integrity made her an icon
her colleagues remember a humble and
kind woman they worked with for more
than two decades
they say they miss working with her
especially when they covered the latest
israeli war on the besieged gaza strip
earlier this month
bashir salame added the last report
shirin worked on before she was killed
now he's editing reports on her legacy
it is tough to continue working there's
a conflict inside of me
at the same time i know that we have to
keep carrying the mantle and raising her
voice
the voice the forcibly wanted to silence
this is our motivation to keep going
many here say it's important to keep
talking about children
not only because she made palestinians
feel heard and seen but also because by
demanding justice for shireen they're
demanding justice for all the people she
reported on in her long and rich career
nida ibrahim al-jazeera the occupied
west bank
well shireen's niece lina about joins us
now from san francisco lena it's really
good to see you it's been 100 days since
your aunt's murder
we talked there about her professional
life and her legacy but 100 days on on a
personal level how are you feeling how
how is the family marking the day
thank you for having me
you know it's been 100 days and i still
wake up and ask myself if i'm in a
nightmare if this is real
100 days have been very difficult for me
and my family
trying to comprehend this insurmountable
loss
but
we continue to fight for justice
continue to fight for accountability
um and trying to keep shileen's legacy
and her memory alive
because by honoring her legacy it means
ensuring that no other journalist no
other palestinian lives
are lost and killed by the israeli
nation forces
and most importantly no other family
should have to endure what our family
has been going through for the past 100
years
that's why we continue to call for
accountability and continue our fights
for justice for shooting
talk us through how that that fight for
justice has been what does full
accountability mean for you
accountability for me and my family is
holding the soldier who killed chilean
responsible holding the entire system
that continues to perpetuate this kind
of
violence and
the chain of command that ordered the
killing of shirin
we are pursuing justice and
accountability through any means
available for us
and uh we have been encouraged by the
support of the
80 members of congress
uh that we
that we received that we saw their
efforts in calling for a u.s
investigation into the murder of the u.s
citizens
uh including um
representative andre carson's the
justice for shilling act and senator van
hollen's efforts in the senate all of
these have given us
some hope
that there will be justice for chilean
no matter what the
no matter how the road is we will not
relent we will continue to push for
accountability i remember when you were
at capitol hill and speaking with some
of those members of congress one of them
said you know if this was anywhere else
in the world
the soldier and the person who ordered
that soldier would be held accountable
but because they are in israeli
uniforms they will not be held
accountable
i mean what does that say to you do you
think that is true do you feel like
there will be some accountability as you
go down this road
of course that statement is true because
because shireen
shireen was is a palestinian-american
so the fact that there is palestinian
before american
has made the entire
uh
entire road towards accountability even
more difficult if shireen was killed
somewhere else there would have been an
investigation from day one there would
have been justice from day one but the
double standards is stark especially
that the u.s continues to preach about
human rights press freedom democracy but
when it comes to its america it's
palestinian-american citizen then then
there's an exception
yes the road is difficult it's tough but
we will not be discouraged
shireen stood for truth she stood for
justice and she would have done the same
if it was anyone else so we will
continue our fight for accountability
and we will continue to publicly speak
out
uh and call on secretary lincoln and the
biden administration to follow through
with meaningful action
and to investigate
uh this this crime
there are murals uh around the
palestinian territories we've got her
reports which we which we watch and look
back on ways to remember her legacy for
you and for your family how do you do
that how do you remember her
we remember shirina every day ever she's
part of our lives you know we continue
to talk about her we continue to
remember her and recite our
stories and memories with chilean i
continue to talk with her friends on
daily basis and share stories with them
and share memories
you know it's been 100 days but every
single day we still talk about chilean
everyone still talks about shireen
shireen continues to be everywhere
and
talking about her
and honoring her legacy
means honoring her exceptional and
everlasting legacy so we will continue
our
our efforts towards making sure that her
legacy is everlasting absolutely i'm i'm
very sorry for your loss lena thank you
for joining us
thank you for having me thank you and we
here at al jazeera also continue to
demand full accountability for shireen's
murder